moving on and the world health
organization says
the world is in danger of losing
hard-won gains in the fight against
covet 19.
it says the highly transmissible delta
variant is spreading in more than
two-thirds of all countries with a
global vaccination gap aiding the spread
now this map shows vaccine doses
administered per 100 people across the
world
and countries shaded in darker blue have
a higher vaccination rate in africa just
1.5 percent of the population has been
vaccinated
[Music]
nancy and danu died of coronavirus
she was 27 years old
is that first of all there were no there
was no enough express nation in this
country
like more than 98 of africans nancy did
not have access to a vaccine in her
homeland of kenya
we had so many plants together
[Music]
until the vaccination rates are high
people will continue to die people will
continue to get sick and we allow
to exist the breeding ground of new
variants that will make people
sicker that will spread to areas that we
think are now
safe and we will erode not only the
health of the populations that we're
working with now but will erode the
health
of the gains that we've made within
countries such as the united states and
europe that do have those high
vaccination rates
the world health organization is
highlighting the urgency of the problem
do you really accept 1.5 percent
vaccination in africa while in some
countries it's already 70 percent
the world is actually
morally epidemiologically and
economically is doing the wrong things
there are huge discrepancies between
vaccination levels
in israel most of the population has
already received two
jobs and some are getting ready to
receive a third booster shot
meanwhile other countries like kenya are
lagging far behind
the fact of the matter is nobody not
here in the uk
not in the united states not in germany
nobody is going to be safe until
everybody is safe
at the last g7 summit the richest
nations agreed to donate one billion
vaccine doses to developing countries
but not to allow a patent waiver china
appears ready to exploit that vacuum by
sharing its technology
synovac has always known that a pandemic
has no borders
the sars outbreak 20 years ago was also
a global pandemic
a massive drive is needed to vaccinate
the world before more variants of covet
19
emerge people keep asking for magic dust
it doesn't exist
the one magic dust we do have is
vaccination problem is
we're not sprinting that evenly around
the world and we're working against
ourselves if preventing deaths like
nancy's does not motivate
high-income countries to show more
solidarity
perhaps self-interest will
[Music]
more than a million people are in
lockdown in china in the country's worst
coronavirus outbreak in months
the delta variant is driving a surge in
cases in the eastern city of nanjing
authorities are mass testing the
population of 9 million people
and cases have also reached beijing and
other several provinces
lockdown mass testing and contact
tracing
same drill different virus variant this
time to combat the more transmissible
delta strain a rise of cases in china
has been linked to a cluster
in the eastern province of jiangsu where
cleaners at an airport in nanjing tested
positive two weeks ago
officials were keen to assert they were
on top of the situation
at the moment the 190 confirmed cases
are all receiving medical treatment in
the hospital in nanjing
all the patients are in a stable
condition on the 30th of july
one severe case was downgraded to a
general one while one general case
became severe
both are in a stable condition one
asymptomatic case is currently under
quarantine for treatment in the hospital
china's disciplinary watchdog blamed
nanjing airport officials for poor
supervision
the health commission has since taken
measures to disinfect the site
the coming days will show if that plus
nanjing testing all of its 9.2
million residents twice will help arrest
delta's spread